moi j'étais ouf de Derrick parce que moi
j'étais très longtemps au chômage et euh
ça me détendait et je me rappelle moi je
regarde direct toute la journée je
dormais devant Eric et je partais de
chez moi parce que ma mère arrivait et
c'était pas c'était pas commode
elle rentrait du travail je peux vous
dire à 20h30 tu vois et moi je suis
encore en train je regardais la télé
toute la journée ça veut dire flash tu
es en pause lit à 20h30 et ma mère
j'avais toujours cette phrase Cyril
qu'est-ce que tu fais je disais rien
elle me dit mon père ou ma mère dit bah
comme d'habitude et donc je sortais à
21h et je revenais que le matin à 8h
tous les soirs j'étais tous les soirs
dehors mais tu disais quoi
chercher un travail pour sortir la vie
quoi oh je te jure je te jure tous les
soirs et je rentrais le matin et je
croisais ma mère qui allait au travail
ça bosse
alors on bosse toujours
[Rires]
à la maison et mon père et mon père
comme il est médecin parfois il avait
son cabinet à côté et mon père le
problème c'est qu'il est il est pas
discret donc on était dans une pente et
quand j'entendais mais moi j'étais et
j'entendais mon père il avait un frein à
main et quand il est arrivé il mettait
il faisait le frein à main fort comme ça
donc dès qu'il arrivait je faisais genre
j'étais en train d'étudier comme un
short et des cahiers mon frère et tout
qu'est-ce que tu fais maintenant je suis
en train d'étudier un petit peu de la
Chine
oui je me sens mieux comme ça
oui oui oui bah écoute comme tu veux moi
j'étudie comme je veux pas ça chez vous
hein
S
par contre je travaille avec mon père ah
ouais je t'ai médecin
[Applaudissements]
bon alors qu'est-ce qui se passe mal de
gorge mais déjà mieux aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'étais complètement ouf mon frère
quoi le cadre
autrement là
frère
moi je m'habillais je m'habillais frère
ma mère me voyait partir faire elle
croyait faire Michel j'allais faire des
trucs de ouf frère mes frères je
m'habiller en fait je passais toute la
journée à me préparer pour sortir le
soir
toute la journée il faisait que ça
photos du boucle d'un comédien ça
frère merci les gars et merci
[Applaudissements]
la tête de votre fils
non mais la tête les yeux regardez comme
ça
c'est mon fils
généralement dans 30 Millions d'Amis ils
ont dit les chiens ne font pas des chats
le cadre est fou le cadre est tout
100000 euros le cadre est fou le cadre
en diamant il est incroyable
j'ai pas envie de parler de ça vous
demanderez aux gens qui étaient avec moi
j'ai pas envie de parler de ça
[Rires]